July 17th 2007 what you were feeling
what you were doing what you're up to
that month I was in a little town in
Wales taking in these castle ruins
experience left a mark on my brain for
sure what about December 13th 2014 that
was a less memorable experience for me
but it was just a normal day at the
house as he was reading a book Henry had
a fever he was sick we had put up
Christmas decorations and gone on a walk
and a little trail in front of our house
not a super memorable day somewhere in
your brain there is stored a memory of
what happened on those two days for you
but it's probably impossible to dig it
up you probably have no idea what you
were doing on July 17th 2007 remembering
this stuff is hard because our brains
aren't built for it think of this circle
as what you're able to recall and
actively think about at any given moment
you've got a few memories and pieces of
information that are really close by in
case you need them like when I ask you
what your phone number is you've got
that super close nice and bright easy to
retrieve but when I ask you to remember
the name of your favorite school teacher
you have to stretch a little bit but
you're eventually able to retrieve it
and throw it into this little circle and
remember it if I asked you to tell me
when was the last time you saw a hamster
you'll scan these bright memories and
you won't find it the last time you saw
a hamster is probably way out here
lurking in some dark part of your brain
it's there but it's totally unreachable
and what's scary is you don't even know
that you can't remember it you can't
remember that you can't remember it you
saw a hamster at some point
but it's gone the vast majority of your
life a thousands of days that you've
spent on this earth are all out here
with a few bright spots for really
important memories that you can retrieve
pretty easily like the first time you
left the country or the day you met your
significant other or that time you broke
your wrist but most of this stuff is
totally unreadable which is totally fine
you probably don't care to remember that
time you've bumped your knee on the door
of your friend's apartment in 2015 but
what about that gathering of friends
that you had that same month where the
conversation was flowing and the food
was so good and you felt alive and
excited about life to me that's worth
remembering like what was the best
experience you had in April of 2011 what
made you happy that month you have no
idea and maybe you don't care to know
what happened in April of 2011 but I do
I think it's a travesty that so much of
our life is simply forgotten I want my
memory to look more like this with the
bright spots not just being the
memorable trips I went on but also the
mundane experiences the things that
happened to me years and years ago like
what if I could somehow remember
simultaneously the memorable stuff like
the first time I wandered through Rio de
Janeiro and the mundane but special
stuff like that time we went to the park
with Izzy's parents when Henry was like
2 years old back in 2015 and had like a
really amazing day had great
conversation Henry was in a good mood
everyone was happy that was a special
day and I want to remember it I've been
thinking about this predicament for many
years and developing processes and
workflows in ways that I can use photos
and video to create a world where I can
easily retrieve memories
[Music]
I want to share with you some of the
guiding principles that I use the
workflows the software's the
philosophies that I use to do this and
hopefully if you're interested you can
start to construct a similar world of
memories
solving this issue has to do with this
you've got this amazing camera with you
at all times but you've probably noticed
that the solution isn't just to take a
bunch of photos a familiar situation is
you take a bunch of photos of things
that you probably want to remember and
then you have so many photos just
sitting on your phone you don't really
know what to do with them you never end
up actually looking at them it's the
great paradox of digital photography and
it's really easy to get out of control
my approach to this involves photos but
it does not involve just taking photos
of everything you want to remember
secondly I have to say that my approach
to this is influenced by the research
that's been done on what happens to your
brain when you take a picture of
something if you're walking along the
cliff sides of Lima Peru and you pull
out your camera to take a photo
something happens in your brain your
brain starts recording less of the non
visual sensations around you so that
bird that's hanging out next to you or
the sound of the ocean or the traffic of
the breeze the smell the way you're
feeling in short the more immersive
experience of being in a place in said
your brain hones in on the visual
aspects of the scene so a year later if
someone asks you what Lima Peru is like
you will probably have a better visual
memory of your experience there but you
won't remember what you were feeling you
won't remember the general experience
you'll remember the things took a photo
of okay you're probably done hearing you
talk about like the theory behind how I
do this and like the broad research and
all that now let me show you how I
actually do this the key to remember in
your life is deleting photos okay I'm
gonna say that again the key to remember
in your life is deleting photos the
antithesis to remember in your life is
too many photos you take a lot of photos
many of them you don't want having them
in your world without you actually want
in them will cause more stress than joy
get used to deleting photos often I
haven't reviewed all of the many many
software's that exist out there for
doing this sort of thing the one thing I
can say is that you want a software that
when you take a photo with your phone
it immediately uploads it to the
Internet and downloads it to your
computer so that any photo you add on
your computer or you take with your
phone you see them in both places I know
Google photos does this Apple photos
this Lightroom mobile does this I'm sure
it's becoming more and more of just a
standard feature for all photo software
so it shouldn't be hard to find the
reason you want to do this is because
the first step to actually getting a
handle on your pictures is having them
in one central library and that's why I
very strongly recommend using software
that when you take a picture on your
phone it shows up on your computer
instead of scrolling through Instagram
or Facebook for once during the day
scroll through your own pictures and
delete there in this process of deleting
photos and making that habit you get the
first benefit of this system which is
you will be looking at your photos more
often you get to a new place or you have
like a fun weekend somewhere and you
take a bunch of like photos and videos
of something and you're like I don't
really need that video like it that's it
that was a cool video and it was a cool
thing but like I don't necessarily need
to remember that in 15 years so like
this I took this photo in Montreal
because I was like oh I want to remember
the Lonely Planet guide that I was using
and the way the trees looked no and I
didn't take one I took like like a bunch
let's get rid of literally all of these
interviewing Hillary Clinton yes
definitely want that photo that was a
really cool day I want to remember that
day I'll pick one and delete the others
I don't need ten pictures of Henry and
Oliver at the paediatrician okay so I'll
go through that's a cute shot that's not
it probably have like 15 that's not you
relive the memories as you're deleting
as I'm deleting them here it's deleting
them on my phone - so the clutter is
reducing across both my devices okay so
from that paediatrician day I've got
four photos are you starting to see how
this works actually I've started to
enjoy these this process that seems like
work but it's actually an effort that
helps you relive these memories and
reduce clutter at the same time if that
photo doesn't do something to your brain
chemistry get rid of it if you're a
photographer I'm gonna talk to you for a
second if you're not a photographer
go get a drink of water because I'm
about to use a bunch of jargon
all right photographer time
photographers are probably thinking I
need to edit my photos I want to work
with raw photos Lightroom was our the
promise for us where they would say no
you can have all of your photos
organized and work with them in roz edit
them in a robust software but also see
them on your phone it seemed like the
promise and for the past six years I've
been using Lightroom both to edit my
photos and to organize them and catalog
them but as my photo library grew it
started to get out of control trying to
manage raw photos that are 40 to 50
megabytes each is just insanity when you
have tens of thousands of photos
theoretically Lightroom is the perfect
software but in practice as the catalog
grows it starts to become less stable
and difficult to work with
I recently had a catalog failed and all
of that metadata that was embedded into
the catalog was lost the edits the Geo
data the keywords and that made me
realize that I can't rely on a program a
catalog file to have all of that really
important information so I still use
Lightroom to edit my photos but then I
immediately export them as high-res
JPEGs with all of the metadata embedded
into it including the Geo tag and
everything and then I import it into
Apple photos as baked I call it baked
because I like that idea of like baking
the raw into a nice JPEG that's like
three megabytes they share much quicker
you don't have to export anything I love
Lightroom and I wish that it could just
be the perfect cure-all software but
it's not alright I'm done talking to
just photographers let's get back into
this just remember the mantra so far the
key to remember in your life is deleting
photos okay so we've talked about the
technology and kind of the work
what about when you're in a beautiful
place what if you're in Porto Portugal
which is one of my favorite cities right
now by the way and it's sunset and
you're in this beautiful place in this
view and you want to document it and
remember the night and the buzz in the
air how do you document that place and
that memory in a way that will help you
relive it later on in your life back to
that research that we talked about when
you're taking a picture of something
you're making a little bit of a
trade-off you're enhancing your visual
memory but you're sacrificing some of
the other sensory memories of the smell
and the vibe and the emotional
experience of being there there is local
music being played there's a smell of
summer in the air there is just a vibe
of excitement and relaxation that you
can't capture with the camera
[Music]
it's amazing light I just want to take a
bunch of pictures and so that's what we
do at first you take a bunch of pictures
but then comes the most important part
after you've taken a bunch of pictures
gotten it out of your system put your
camera away and let your brain do the
document
[Music]
you have that visual information saved
in photos now it's time for your brain
to capture the other sensory information
to smell the breeze the sounds all of
that experience that you can't get with
the camera the photos you took will be
put onto a computer I'll delete probably
80 or 90% of them keep just 17 pictures
from that night of the hundreds I took
and those photographs will serve as a
link a gateway to that memory and it
will hopefully spark in my brain all of
that other sensory information that I
experience it okay so now it's time for
what I see is the payoff of all of this
if you are intentional in your efforts
to cull down and delete photos and to be
in moments when you're in moments and to
let those sink into your brain and to
capture them as well if you do all of
that intentional labor now you are in
the amazing position to be able to what
I call explore your memory
[Music]
to go back and to spark those moments
and those feelings again so you can do
this several ways use a million ways but
the way I choose to do it is to go into
Apple photos where I have all of my
photos in one catalogue and to zoom out
you can zoom out two years which is
basically you can see an entire map of
all of your photos year by year pick a
year 2015 we went driving in Florida to
look at some manatees again I totally
forgotten about this experience in tow
right now here we are we go in saw the
manatees and then we drove back and I
remember our car broke down we were on
the side of the road for a bunch of
hours waiting for a tow truck and there
we are and I took a bunch of photos that
night just because I had nothing to do
and the light was pretty cool I probably
had a couple hundred photos just because
I was bored but I only kept four photos
of the the breakdown and that's enough
for me that image right there of the van
broken down on the side of the road is
enough to spark that entire memory
because it's so vivid and it captures so
much of that moment that shot mixed with
Izzy sitting there reading a book by the
light of her phone in her swimsuit is
enough to spark that memory for me and
to help me relive it and to feel all
those feelings again
so that is effectively the general
approach to how I think about
documenting my life it maybe seems
simple like take photos and organize
them but there's some foundational
concepts in there that I think people
miss out on that make a huge difference
so to review find a good photo software
that syncs your photos to the internet
and
to your devices you have a backup and
you have them easily accessible on both
devices this will lead you to deleting
your photos deleting deleting delete
most of the photos you take only keep
the ones that spark a memory or spark
joy for you when you go on trips or
you're in places that you really want to
remember have some camera free time put
the camera away and try to document the
experience with your brain only this
paired with intentional photographing of
that place will later lead to more
immersive memories and a better way to
relive those experiences in a way that
isn't just visual but is sensory
generally and finally the payoff don't
forget if you do all those other steps
to then explore your memory spend time
going through those old photos and
remembering why you kept them trying to
relive those experiences that you want
to relive and this also helps you come
to terms with the fact that everything
is temporary and it passes way it
changes and that things that seem like a
really big deal that are stressful now
probably won't be stressful in two and a
half years when you're scrolling through
the photos from today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]